if you're a member of the Adventist
Church it is time to think long and hard
about these statements and why you would
want to remain in a movement that
upholds someone who wrote something so
Blasphemous and Damned
[Music]
what's up YouTube as always welcome to
the channel so we're continuing our
series and examining the Jesus of
adventism up and against the Jesus of
history and scripture if you missed the
last two parts I suggest checking those
out first the link to both is in the
description box down below in part one
we looked a little bit about the
Adventist Church calls the great
controversy and how Jesus was supposedly
exalted to be made equal with the father
in part two we looked at what Ellen
White said regarding Jesus not being the
Lord God Almighty and today we're going
to look at what she said regarding Jesus
and his resurrection in John Chapter 2
the Apostle documents down the infamous
cleansing of the temple in Jesus
flipping tables then in verse 18 we read
this
so the Jews said to him what sign do you
show us for doing these things Jesus
answered them destroy this Temple and in
three days I will raise it up the Jews
then said it's taken 46 years to build
this Temple and you will raise it up in
three days but he was speaking about the
Temple of his body when therefore he was
raised from the dead his disciples
remembered that he had said this and
they believed the scripture and the word
that Jesus had spoken
so Jesus made it clear when foretelling
of his death and resurrection that he
would partake in raising himself from
the dead John documents this again in
the 10th chapter where he says
I am the Good Shepherd I know my own and
my own know me just as the father knows
me and I know the father and I lay down
my life for the sheep and I have other
sheep that are not of this fold I must
bring them also and they will listen to
my voice so there will be one flock one
Shepherd for this reason the father
loves me because I lay down my life that
I may take it up again no one takes it
from me but I lay it down of my own
accord I have authority to lay it down
and I have authority to take it up again
this charge I have received from my
father
so I mentioned in the last series that
we'll be getting into the Trinity next
in light of the Adventist Heavenly Trio
so I will save the trinitarian aspect of
the Resurrection for them but I want to
focus on Jesus for now notice what he
said twice in this pericope he has the
authority to lay his life down and take
it up again Jesus plainly foretold of
his death on numerous occasions and very
plainly said that he would raise himself
from the dead so with this in mind let's
now look at this in light of the
Adventist Jesus in faith I live by on
page 50 Ellen White writes the following
he who died for the sins of the world
was to remain in the Tomb the allotted
time he was in that Stony prison house
as a prisoner of divine Justice he was
responsible to the judge of the universe
he was bearing the sins of the world and
his father only could release him
so in contrast to the Jesus of scripture
The Seventh-Day Adventist prophetess who
they believe was inspired no differently
than that of the biblical writers and
that her writing speak with prophetic
Authority tells us that Jesus was a
prisoner in the Tomb and Only God the
Father could resurrect him in one of her
most popular books The Desire of Ages on
page 753 she writes the following
Satan with his Fierce Temptations rung
the Heart of Jesus the Savior could not
see through the portals of the Tomb hope
did not present to him his coming forth
from the grave of conqueror or tell him
of the father's acceptance of his
sacrifice he feared that sin was so
offensive to God that their separation
was to be
eternal
so I want you to think for a moment
Satan a creature was able to twist the
mind of God causing him to doubt his
resurrection and if his sacrifice would
be accepted by his father
besides this Blasphemous heresy which
essentially says Jesus doubted which is
unbelief and unbelief is a sin he
apparently forgot what he had said
multiple times previously throughout his
ministry that with absolute certainty he
would raise himself from the dead the
Adventist Church will try and defend
this by saying that Ellen White was only
speaking on Christ's Humanity here that
as a man these are the things he was
experiencing but this only furthers the
problem for them and creates division
within the two Natures of Christ there
was never any division between both
Christ humanity and his divinity but
Ellen presents a Christ that has
internal conflict between his Divine and
human Natures as well as conflict within
the godhead regarding the Son and the
father and a potentiality for Eternal
separation amongst them again I ask is
this the Jesus of scripture and history
no it is not it is a Christ presented by
someone who had zero business claiming
to speak on behalf of God or that they
never wrote a single sentence of heresy
if you're a member of the Adventist
Church it is time to think long hard
about these statements and why you would
want to remain in a movement that
upholds someone who wrote something so
Blasphemous and damnable if you liked
today's video and found it helpful
please be so kind as to smash that like
button subscribe and ring the
notification Bell so you can be notified
when content like this is uploaded as
always I'll catch you guys around next
time
God bless
[Music]